my end goal for this lecture and the
following lecture is to draw for you a
connection between trigonometry and
complex numbers and I really do think
when you understand that connection
between the two it strengthens your
understanding of both of them so for
this lecture we're just going to go back
to the basics on some of the
trigonometric functions how to think
about them what they mean and to dive
into it what I want to first do is
imagine that you don't actually know any
trigonometry yet but show how just
playing around with a graphing
calculator can lead you to come to some
pretty non-trivial facts about trig so
for example let's say you've never heard
of the cosine function but then one day
you know it comes up you hear someone
talking about physics and they mention a
sinusoidal wave and the cosine function
and things like that so you go to a
graphing calculator or something like
desmos and you just poke it in and say
okay what does this thing look like
now before seeing its definition you can
understand oh yeah I can see how this
might be relevant to waves and wave type
dynamics that people might want to study
it's got kind of a cycling phenomenon to
it so maybe anytime people are studying
something associated with cycling you
could play around with the graph and do
all the things that you can with any
normal function if I tweak the input it
kind of squishes it right so as I put a
bigger constant in front of that input X
it squishes things gives it a higher
frequency okay
that's all well and good you could
stretch it out in the Y direction by
messing with the output now what I want
to do though is point out something very
interesting about the cosine graph that
is something you might want to take note
of so what I'm gonna do is square it and
I don't want to show you what it looks
like yet I want you to predict what it's
going to look like when we take cosine
of x squared okay and in particular I'm
just gonna have you focus in on the
region from 0 up to 2 pi so again if
you're just playing around what you
would notice is cosine is clearly
related to PI and probably circles in
some way so it takes a dip down 2 pi
down to negative 1
at pi excuse me and then it comes right
back up to 1 at the input 2 pi so what I
want you to do is predict what it looks
like when we take cosine of x squared
and let's actually do this as one of our
fun live question dynamics ok so getting
rid of our Randi which was a very
informed
thing for me let's dump into our very
first genuinely mathematical quiz
question what does it say here what will
the graph of f of X equals cosine of x
squared look like okay and it looks like
a as an option has these sort of valleys
where in all of these it might be a
little small to read but the range is
going from zero to about two pi so in a
it hits one and then it goes down and
hits one again at the input PI and kind
of goes down with these flat valleys B
has a similar behavior for when it hits
one and zero but it's a little spike
here so it's kind of bouncing right off
that x-axis see looks just like a
sinusoidal wave okay it looks like the
same kind of wave but it's all positive
and it's it goes from one down to zero
then up to one in the span of pi and
then D kind of gets scrunched together
in the X direction and starts going more
rapidly as you move farther to the right
okay so it looks like we've got a lot of
answers coming in a fair bit of
consensus towards the top but it's not
definitely not a unanimous decision on
this one where people are going so it
seems like there's one most popular
answer and then to that kind of tie
closely for the silver and the bronze
medals so I'm going to give you just a
couple more seconds here if you want to
change your mind or if you want to go to
3 B 1 B KO slash live and answer this as
we're going the link is also in the
description if you just want to click it
there
clink click it there and alright I think
that's probably enough time let's go
ahead and grade this what do you think
it will be all right it looks like a
majority of you went with C which is the
one that looks like a sinusoidal wave
this is the second most common one was a
which has a similar shape but it's kind
of more flattened out on the bottom
third most common was B and then the the
last most common was D and I think
that's pretty good instincts because a B
and C which were the top three choices
there if we go back and look at our
actual cosine graph itself what you'll
notice is that at the input 0 its 1 so
when you square that 1 squared should
stay 1 similarly negative 1 when you
square that that should come up
as well and then positive one at the end
of its cycle again that's one so the
idea that no matter what you're going to
get something that dips down to zero
then up to one down to zero and up to
one should make sense but the specific
shape is what we don't know turns out as
you just saw the answer is C so if we go
over here and reveal it looks just like
a little cosine wave which is weird if
you think about it because what we're
doing when we square something is
affecting the output it's affecting
stuff happening in the Y direction right
but to get another cosine wave that's
oscillating more quickly it's not at all
clear that that's what would happen
and using this even before you know what
the cosine of X means if you're just
playing around being kind of childlike
with your graphing calculator you can
discover a pretty non-trivial fact about
trigonometric functions and then as we
start defining them and getting into
them you will appreciate just how
non-trivial it is because it really is
not obvious so for this I want to take
us to a second question okay and I would
look at this graph hard K remember that
it looks like a scaled-down version of
the cosine graph and what I'm going to
want you to do is basically come up with
an identity based on that okay so
question number two what does it say
working from the assumption that the
graph of cosine of x squared looks like
a scaled down version of the graph of
cosine of X which of the following
equations is true okay now because this
might take a little moment for you guys
to work out pencil and paper highly
encourage you to actively work it out
I'm just gonna give you know maybe 30 to
60 seconds to start penciling through
noodling it out and let's uh let's
introduce a little bit of pause and
ponder music just to put us in the
problem-solving mode I think so which
one of these reflects the fact the
cosine of x squared is kind of a scaled
version of itself
so it looks like we still have a fair
bit of answers rolling in and I don't
want you to feel rushed so I'm gonna
give you time to figure it out for
yourself if you want to while you're
answering this it looks like we've got
ourselves a question that's rolled in
okay so Diego Mathemagician love the
name asks what is the new music great
question so the guy who usually composes
the music for the channel his name is
Vince Vince Ruben Eddie I told him that
we were doing these streams and I
mentioned I wanted kind of a jeopardy
here I'll turn it down to it I can talk
over it Vince your music is great but I
want to talk about it a little bit more
I wanted just a Jeopardy type theme but
mixed with the usual three blue and
brown vibe so a little clock ticking and
I think it really puts you in the
problem-solving mood now that is
probably enough to noodle this one out
so I'm going to go ahead and grade this
and I'm guessing the majority have
gotten it correct okay great job so to
the 3165 of you that answered B which is
that it's 1/2 cosine of 2x plus 1
congratulations you're absolutely
correct but let's let's think about how
you might do that in a step-by-step way
and this is one of those things that
again if you're just noodling around on
a graphing calculator you can come to so
what I might do is take here I'll just
I'll go ahead and write a new cosine
function ok and then I'm going to start
manipulating it so cosine of X we won't
look at the original the first thing
you'd notice is ok we want to make it
entirely positive because that's what
the other one is so maybe I'm going to
shift it up by one ok and that makes it
all positive but now it's twice as high
as the other graph we're looking at so
if we want to make it equal we might
chop it in half but it still cycles once
every 2 pi right you have to go from 0
all the way up to 2 pi before this blue
graph that we're looking at goes through
the cycle from 1 down to 0 now back up
to 1 so the last step is going to be to
squish it in the x-direction and
sometimes people find this rainy encode
in counterintuitive that you scale up
that input that you multiply it by to in
order
to squish it but what's really going on
if you think it through is we want to
say instead of taking two pi to go
through your full cycle I want you to go
through that cycle as X ranges from zero
to PI so if we make that input to X then
the thing being plugged into cosine will
go from zero to two pi as X goes from
zero up to PI and what you'll look at is
the graphs are right on top of each
other right which is very cool right on
top of each other and that means you've
discovered a pretty non-trivial fact
about trigonometry and it's worth
writing down because it's one of those
things that comes up later in a very
hard to memorize way I always had a
little bit of trouble actually
remembering what this thing is so
writing down what you just found cosine
of x squared okay is equal to one plus
cosine of two x which is basically
saying increase its frequency so we're
going to double its frequency and then
add one to it so it's going to shift
above that y-axis and then we're going
to divide that by two okay so this is a
fact that we're going to turn back to at
the very end of the lecture and as you
start to get an appreciation for what
the cosine means it becomes clearer and
clearer just how non-obvious this is and
in particular the one thing I want you
to take note of is the weird fact that
we've got this function that when you
square it it's not equal to but it's
somewhat related to the idea of scaling
up that input now if you were clever
there is another function that behaves
very similarly to this where when you
square it it's the same as doing
something to its input and this actually
takes us to our next question
so let's go ahead and move past from
this one okay and I'm going to ask you
something that seems very unrelated to
trigonometry and it'll take us until the
neck like next lecture excuse me to
realize just how related it is what is
our question say which of the following
functions satisfies f of 2x is equal to
f of x squared okay so when you plug in
2x that should be the same as f of x
squared option a square root of 1 minus
x squared
option B log of X option C
x-squared an option D 2 to the X okay so
I'm gonna give you a couple minutes know
a little bit to answer that we won't
take too long on this one no it looks
like I accidentally created it right
away well so sorry for everyone who felt
a little bit rushed there my finger
slipped
well in either case it's now been
revealed that the answer is d 2 to the X
okay and we can we can see this again if
we go and just play around a little bit
in our desmos graphs so what we might do
is pop over here and let me plug in 2 to
the X look at what that graph looks like
so let's not look at our cosines anymore
2 to the X and indeed if I take this
whole thing and I square it on the one
hand squaring usually does a kind of
stretching motion in the Y direction but
what's neat about this shape is that
it's exactly the same as taking 2 to the
2x and if you know anything about
exponents this kind of makes sense
because that 2 up here can get
distributed into that X but what this
means is that exponents have this funny
property that when you square them it's
a lot like scaling the input and of
course the reason I bring that up is
that you're looking at something very
similar when it comes to cosine just
before just by playing around with
graphs before you even know what they
mean you can have this tiny little
instinct in your head that says maybe
just maybe cosine is somehow related to
exponents it's not at all obvious how it
is but it absolutely is and that's what
one of the things that I'd like to get
to by the end of the end of the section
like second lecture we won't get the end
of there today so with all of that I
think it's high time that we actually
talked about what sine and cosine
actually are I don't want to come in
assuming that you necessarily know that
already
so let's have a little moment to go back
to the basics I think one of the best
summaries of trigonometry that I ever
heard and this was on reddit but I
cannot for the life of me find it
remember who originally said this is you
think that it's about triangles but
really it's about circles and this is
absolutely true I think between the time
when I very first learned about
trigonometry and
now I think my mind shifted from
fundamentally thinking of a triangular
based definition which we'll talk about
in a moment two circles and let me just
show you what I mean with respect to the
circles because that's the one that
explains how it comes up in physics and
often how to get intuitions about where
the values will be so instead of our
desmos graph I'm going to go ahead and
pull up a couple animations here so in
this one I'll explain what sine of theta
is where theta is the input and it's
going to be a measure of how far you've
walked around a circle so I want you to
imagine that you've started on the
rightmost side of a circle that has a
radius of one okay and then as you walk
around at a constant rate as a function
of how far you've walked we're gonna
graph your height which is to say your
y-axis on this grid maybe it's think of
it as the distance between you and the
x-axis and as you do that you get this
wave that oscillates and it kind of
makes sense how it's just going to
oscillate on and on no matter how far
you walk which is why when we go back
over to the desmos graph and you think
of something like cosine of X not the
squared version let's just do the plain
vanila cosine X you know it goes on
forever continuing to cycle like this
and I guess here I'm explaining sine of
X but it works the same way if instead I
type sine of X we get a similar looking
shape the only difference is that it
starts at zero and we can take a look to
explain why here because if by
definition if it's giving you a your y
coordinate when you start off to the
right it starts at zero before slowly
increasing okay now by contrast cosine
it's defined very similarly but it's
giving you the x coordinate as you walk
around that circle so the distance to
the vertical line and in that context it
starts off at one and then as you walk
around the circle your distance from
that y-axis your x coordinate is going
to get lower it ultimately gets down to
negative one before it starts increasing
again okay so this is how you might
think of sine and cosine with respect to
circles the input is a kind of it's a
kind of distance a
a unit circle but you can think of that
as an angle and we're going to talk in a
moment about the difference between
degrees and radians but when you're
thinking about walking around the circle
if it has a radius of 1 you can think of
that input as being the literal distance
that you walk so as an example notice
what happens when we get to the distance
pi okay
pi gives you the semi circumference of
one of these circles if it's got a
radius of one then the distance that it
takes to get halfway around is PI which
is why at that input PI you see the
output go to negative one at half of
that if you turned a 90-degree angle
which means walking around a distance of
PI halves
that's why cosine is 0 at that point so
now I'm going to ask you another
question where we're going to consider
the input in terms of this idea of a
distance around the unit circle okay and
I'm just gonna have you guess at some of
the values for sine and cosine so we'll
go ahead and pull up our quiz again and
this time let's get it up on here what
does that question say without looking
it up or using a calculator which of the
following is true and it's reminding us
that that input 3 is going to be
considered in radians which is to say
the distance around the unit circle if
you're just walking along at the arc
length okay option a the sine of 3 is
around point 1 4 and the cosine of 3 is
around point 9 9 be the sine of 3 is
around point 1 4 and the cosine of 3 is
around negative 0.99 see sine of 3 is
around point 9 9 cosine of 3 is around
point 1 4 and D sine of 3 is around
negative 0.99 and cosine of 3 is around
0.14 okay so just to give you a little
moment to think that through it seems
like there's not a hundred percent
consensus on this question and answers
are still rolling in so I'm gonna go
ahead and give you a little bit of pause
and ponder music I'll let you just think
about it I don't want you to feel rushed
here
ok so I think this is probably a pretty
good time to start grading things so the
correct answer is B and it looks like
the majority of you got the correct
answer which is to say that sign is 0.14
and cosine is negative 0.99 now the
specific numbers here don't matter
what's actually relevant is just kind of
whether it's positive or negative and
whether it's very close to 1 or if it's
closer to 0 so if we think through what
this might mean in the context of our
graphs here the cosine which remember is
measuring the x-coordinate of your
little dot as you walk around the circle
what is that going to be when you input
3 well what does it mean to walk 3 units
around the circle
well like I just mentioned walking PI
units around the circle gets you halfway
around this is really the way to think
about pi is it's you've got a unit
circle it takes you halfway around so to
walk three units is gonna be something a
little bit shy of that ok and if you
notice there's very little change in the
x direction as you're at that left side
of the circle so when it approaches one
it gets really close to one and then it
doesn't really change that much so maybe
it shouldn't be too surprising that our
cosine of three turned out to be around
0.99 what what excuse me what's relevant
is that it's negative right it's very
close to negative one so it's close to
negative 0.99 now on the other hand if
we were doing this with sign which same
game but it's measuring your
y-coordinate when you walk almost
halfway around which is to say almost pi
radians well there's still a little bit
of height left and importantly it's
positive because you're still above that
x-axis so when we turned back to our
question the only thing differentiating
our answers was that some of them would
switch whether sine or cosine was the
one that's close to negative one and the
others would just switch the sign s IGN
whether it's positive or negative so
congratulations to the 3152
of you who got that one correct so
that's loosely how you might think about
sine and cosine if we're coming at it
from the direction of circles but this
is very different from how it's usually
taught if we're doing things like in a
typical high school class where you
start off thinking about right triangles
one is not better they're just
very different and worth understanding
the connection so the classic thing when
it comes to trig functions is a little
statement that everyone has ringing
through their head called so kah TOA
okay and what you're supposed to
remember from this is if we have a right
triangle so let me go ahead and draw a
right triangle so we know one of the
angles is 90 degrees and if you know
another one of the angles theta then
consider one of the sides to be the
hypotenuse and then you ask what what of
the other two legs is adjacent to that
angle and we label at a for adjacent and
which of them is opposite so then
sohcahtoa if that's a phrase that you
remember running through your head
tells you that the sine of this angle
this is the definition of sine for some
kind of angle that we input is for such
a right triangle it's the opposite over
the hypotenuse that's what this is
telling us opposite over hypotenuse
similarly the cosine of that angle is
going to equal the adjacent over the
hypotenuse so that would be adjacent
over hypotenuse okay and then the
tangent of that angle is going to be the
opposite over the adjacent okay so that
opposite side o over the adjacent side
so there's the classic thing to remember
if students come out of a trig class if
they know one thing they typically know
sohcahtoa right and to give us an
example of how you might apply this I'm
gonna go ahead and pull up another
question here for you which is gonna ask
us about a leaning tower a leaning tower
of pizza clearing out the last one let's
read what our new question has to say
suppose that a tower is 100 meters high
after several years this tower the tower
starts to lean so instead of making a 90
degree angle with the ground it makes an
80 degree angle when the Sun is directly
overhead what is the length of the
tasked by this leaning tower okay the
length of the shadow cast by this
leaning tower I would highly encourage
you to try drying this out yourself I'm
absolutely gonna draw it for you in a
moment but it's more fun if you're
engaged and if you have a pencil and
paper to noodle it out you could also
try to imagine it in your head if you
want but for me at least I always think
much more clearly
once I have pencil and paper no matter
how much I think I can think things
through in my head so let's give you a
little pause and ponder time on this one
looks like we have some very strong
consensus on this one which is very
reassuring and I guess one thing that
should maybe go without saying
especially given that I've turned the
super chat or the live chat into the
very aggressive slow mode this is most
fun if you don't know what the majority
of people are already thinking right the
whole idea of the statistics is right
now you can see there's a bandwagon
right there's twenty six hundred people
who are voting for one of the answers
who think that's it but we don't know
what one of those answers is so if you
have the answer try not to just blurt it
out in the live chat that's kind of the
equivalent of a student in a classroom
where when the teacher asks something
rather than raising their hand to ask it
or submitting it quietly just shouting
okay I get it you're excited you really
want to do it but in this case it's a
little bit more fun if we have this low
reveal all right so that's probably
enough time for people to have rolled
their answers in now let's go ahead and
see what they see what the majority has
submitted and the correct answer is B
which is 100 times the cosine of 80 and
it looks like the second most common
answer was a which is a hundred times
the sine of eighty so it looks like you
guys correctly knew that you were
multiplying it by one of these
trigonometric functions but there might
have just been a little swap up for
which one was which so let's think this
through okay let's go back to our paper
and our question had us imagine a tower
which is a hundred meters tall and
specifically it said it was a hundred
meters tall and then it started tilting
so we can think of the the length of the
towers 100 meters that's not necessarily
how far its new top is off of the ground
and then it has this imagine that
there's the Sun directly overhead okay
so it's going to be casting a shadow
perpendicular to the ground that's what
gives us our nice right triangle and it
further specified that the angle here
was 80 degrees okay so the thing we want
to know is this side here the length of
the shadow which if we look at our
sohcahtoa that's the adjacent side so we
might write for ourselves cosine of this
angle which is
80 degrees is equal to that adjacent
side the thing that we want to know I'll
just call it X or maybe I'll call it s
foreshadow tried to give our variables
readable meanings divided by the
hypotenuse which is a hundred so that
means that the shadow once we rearrange
is 100 times the cosine of 80 degrees
now already this feels very different
from the thought of trigonometry via
circles like I said you start to think
about it in terms of triangles later it
comes to circles
one of the main differences here is that
we're dealing with a different unit
right here I was saying degrees and
that's very natural when we're in the
context of triangles we could also talk
about angles in terms of radians like
I'll say in a moment but we humans
assign numbers a numerical system to
things we really like whole numbers
between 0 and 100 that we just love that
instead of thinking of proportions we
think in terms of percentages which is
the same thing but it just turns it to
whole numbers between 0 and 100 when we
think about like sound with decibels
which scales a whole bunch and it's got
this crazy exponential pattern to it we
logarithmic really change it and we have
this very awkward system that's really
twisting the math behind its back so
that we can think of whole numbers
between 0 and 100 same deal with what's
going on with degrees but mathematicians
don't really like that they don't really
like to think in terms of degrees
because it's so unnatural instead they
want some sort of natural unit something
where you imagine if you talk to an
alien civilization about math they would
have the same conventions so how does
any of this connect to the unit circle
and the idea of the distance around that
unit circle that we were walking like we
saw earlier well let me just pull up a
pre-printed unit circle because trust me
you don't want to see me try to draw a
circle what's neat here is we can for
each of these triangles imagine
rescaling it so that that hypotenuse is
really one because all we care about our
ratios of lengths of sides so we might
as well say okay let's scale this so
that the hypotenuse is 1 meaning we
divide everything by H and what that's
going to get us is the opposite side is
now o over H whatever that was and then
the adjacent side is a over H
meaning that the wykel component here is
sine of theta where theta was our angle
down here okay and then that bottom part
is cosine of theta okay and if we want
to think about all possible right
triangles who have a hypotenuse of one
well you might think of is taking a unit
circle because that's saying every point
is a distance of one away so think of
that line as the hypotenuse of a
triangle if you have a triangle with a
bigger angle it shows up there if you
have a triangle with a smaller angle it
shows up there and it says if you take
all possible right triangles and you fix
them so that their points are all in
common and search that their hypotenuse
is are all one you scaled them down and
the other tip of the triangle is going
to trace out a unit circle like this and
each one of these points for the
corresponding angle is going to have
coordinates cosine of theta as the
x-coordinate and then sine of theta for
the y-coordinate and I'm just writing it
vertically so I can fit it all on here
okay now typically like I said
mathematicians like to think in terms of
radians which is really a way of saying
if we know that the radius of our circle
is 1 what is the distance that you've
walked along the outside here yeah so
for example if you were to say 180
degrees excuse-me degrees which is
walking halfway around the circle that's
the same as pi radians and if you were
to take something like 60 degrees okay
which would maybe end up oh I don't know
around here that might be 60 degrees
well that's a third of that you're
walking a third of the half turn around
the circle everyone who's an enthusiast
about tau is sort of yelling right now
because it would make the conventions
easier but pi is the standard so we're
working with it it's PI thirds radians
so from this point forward and really
for a lot of your math career I would
encourage you to in every time you want
to think in terms of degrees where that
makes the angle intuitive try to
translate it to radians because that's
going to be the more natural way to
understand it and the farther you get
down the road when it comes to how sine
and cosine play into calculus how you
actually find values of them almost all
of the time it's easier to think of that
input in in terms of radians so I think
it's high time I I asked you a couple
questions about these and you might
wonder you know how do we actually
compute some of the values right how to
compute and the almost answer is that
it's hard if there was an easy answer to
say oh well this is the formula that
shows you what sine of theta is we
wouldn't have given sine of theta a
fancy name we would just always work in
terms of that formula and we would call
it the circle y-coordinate formula and
it might get a name but it wouldn't be a
special function it wouldn't have a
special button on your calculator
because effectively what you have to do
is before you know fancy techniques
associated with calculus or associated
with even fancier things like what's
known as the quartic algorithm you could
just have to have a handful of values
that you do know that come from
geometric settings where there's enough
symmetry so for example let's say I try
to draw an equilateral triangle okay an
equilateral triangle will be nice and
symmetric and we're going to be able to
leverage that symmetry to figure out a
concrete value of sine and cosine
this looks roughly equilateral wouldn't
you say and let's say each of those side
links is one because you know if we get
to choose our side lengths why not one
because remember sine and cosine have
everything to do with just ratios so on
an equilateral triangle this angle here
is 1/3 of the total the total is 180
degrees so you might think of this as 60
degrees but like I said earlier I would
encourage you to try to get in the habit
of thinking of that instead of 60
degrees say okay the full angle is PI so
a third of that is going to be PI thirds
and then similarly this one up here is
half that angle here's where we're
leveraging that symmetry to some extent
that one is 30 degrees which in terms of
radians is now a sixth of a a sixth of a
half turn all the Tallinn theists get
very mad at this point but again hey
it's the convention this is the thing
that you should come out of a trig class
knowing in your head
how to think in terms of radians
measured in PI because that's how we
that's how we often write it down in
tests and such so that one will be PI
sixths so one thing I might ask you now
is if you can leverage the symmetry of
the set up the fact that equilateral
triangles are going to be very nice and
that the right triangle coming about
from it is very nice to answer something
like a very concrete calculation what is
the sine of PI sixths okay what do you
think it is and in fact let's do this as
another live question which as you can
see I'm like a kid in a candy shop I'm
just very enthusiastic with my new toy
so let's go ahead and use it pull up
another question here and what is our
question asked what is the sine of pi/6
of course so again if you want if you're
just joining now you can hop over to
three b-1b cows live you can answer that
I imagine the best way to do this if
you're doing it live is you might be
answering on your phone watching on
another screen or if you want to switch
between tabs that's also good now while
those answers are rolling in let's take
a look to see if we have anything from
the audience and we do when you do maths
problems do you use pen or pencil for
sure I use pencil one I'm very error
prone so I'm gonna make mistakes all the
time the only reason I'm writing in pen
now is because it shows up better on the
camera and let me just tell you with
every stroke that I write I'm deeply
terrified that there's about to be an
error because I know there will be so if
that terror doesn't show in the shaking
of my hands then you'll start to notice
it from this point forward back to our
question though it looks like we've got
pretty strong consensus now around two
thousand ninety-one people agreeing on
one of the answers and then a pretty
even split among the other ones oh no no
I guess the length of the bar is a
little whoever worked on this game
you may be a little bit misleading it
looks like one of the answers is much
less popular than the other two but I
guess the its considering them to start
from somewhere like that maybe we should
have some axes on that are indicating
that so there's one very unpopular
answer and then one very popular answer
so let's go ahead and see what that
turns out to be correct answer is
one-half
congratulations to the twenty eight
hundred no no twenty 915 of you coming
into the last minute there to poll in a
correct answer okay so why is that the
case right why is he like necessarily
gonna be one-half well remember sine of
pi/6 we're asking sohcahtoa to kind of
remember in your head sine is opposite
over adjacent opposite over hypotenuse
excuse me
so with respect to this smaller angle
and they all change colors with respect
to this smaller angle the opposite side
is this segment here and because of the
symmetry of our triangle that's going to
be one half because each side length of
the equilateral triangle is one so half
of it should be one half and divided by
the hypotenuse but by definition the
hypotenuse was one here so one half
divided by one it's just the same as one
half now slightly trickier is if I'd ask
you the cosine of pi/6 and let's do this
one again as a live quiz but maybe a
little bit more quickly this time I'm
gonna hop over get to our next question
and as you might expect the next
question is going to ask you to find the
cosine of pi divided by six there we go
and your options are a 1/2 be square
root of 2/2 see square root of 3/2 or d
square root of 5/2 if you can I would
HIGHLY encourage you to be keeping your
own notes right so if you wanted to kind
of check back on your own piece of paper
you could take a look through it as
you're working out these questions but
for right now I'm just going to give you
maybe 20 seconds or so to kind of noodle
to it think of what it might be get a
little pause and ponder music going
okay once again it looks like we have
some pretty kind of strong consensus
from about the same number of people
that we had before so let's go ahead and
grade the answers and the correct one is
C square root of three divided by two so
congratulations to the 3183 of you who
knew that it was square root of three
divided by two
now how do you figure something like
that out well the trick is basically if
you have one of these right triangles if
you know one of their sides then you
know both of them so let me draw a
little copy for ourselves here we know
that the hypotenuse is one one of the
side lengths is one half and the only
thing that's missing if we're thinking
the cosine of 30 degrees is this
adjacent side so because we were doing
it with the angle up there adjacent side
is here now the Pythagorean theorem
tells us that that adjacent value
squared plus the other leg length
squared is going to equal one squared
our hypotenuse squared which means that
value is equal to the square root of one
minus well what's 1/2 squared it's 1/4
which means it is the square root of 1
minus 1/4 is 3/4 so we can go ahead and
take the square root of that bottom and
just leave the radical on the top and
what we get is the square root of 3 all
divided by 2 now this is a value that
any anybody coming out of a trig class
becomes very familiar with they're like
okay if the answer isn't 1/2 it's going
to be square root of 3 over 2 or root 2
over 2 also comes up in another
circumstance but this is one of those
that kind of becomes burned in your
memory square root of 3/2
and one very important fact that's come
about here that's worth highlighting is
that how does the Pythagorean
Pythagorean theorem play into our
trigonometry because if we have a right
triangle whose hypotenuse is 1 and we
know that one of the side lengths let's
let me switch to thinking with respect
to this lower left angle again if one of
the side lengths is cosine of theta and
one of them is sine of theta
well the Pythagorean theorem tells us
that cosine of x squared plus sine of x
squared is always equal to 1 squared
okay now this is a very important
identity it basically tells you if you
know cosine you know sine if you know
sine you know cosine and it also is
giving you a little reminder that it's
all really about the Pythagorean theorem
in fact this is equivalent to the
Pythagorean theorem because if you think
of how cosine and sine are defined it's
just defined in terms of the leg lengths
of a right triangle and then everything
scaled down as needed
now there's one very silly convention
with how we write these things so we've
already started to make friends with the
cosine of x squared function and the
fact that is a little more interesting
than you might think at first sight but
you never see it written down as open
parenthesis cosine of X close
parenthesis squared because people don't
want to write too many parenthesis
instead they write cosine squared of X
plus sine squared of X it's all very
nice how lovely
we don't have to write too many symbols
what a wonderful convention except for
the fact that literally every other time
in math you see something written as f
squared of X what that means is not F of
x squared that's almost never what it
means instead what it's supposed to mean
for most of math is taking a function
and applying it to itself
you're like layering it over itself
that's what that too usually refers to
sometimes later on it refers to the
second derivative especially if it has
some parentheses around it but the idea
is that it's very different from the
convention in trigonometry trigonometry
is just flying by its own rules and
saying yeah yeah we've got our own
conventions for what it means when we
feel a little too up there I understand
some students will be confused but I'm
trigonometry I don't care I'm moving
forward my conventions and that's fine
right you get used to it this is the
standard way that you'll end up seeing
it what I was writing earlier when we
were thinking about the cosine squared
function which again is very interesting
you would almost always see it written
as Coast squared of X
now very interesting is that this is not
just a consequence of the Pythagorean
theorem that gives us a relation between
our trig functions at the end of the
lecture I want to show you how we can
use trig functions to prove the
Pythagorean theorem in a sneaky way and
it's pretty sneaky like it's it's not
one of the common proofs that you'll see
that's associated with you know
rearranging triangles or anything like
that but it is very visually satisfying
so that's something that we'll get to by
the end of the lecture but in the
meantime I want to think through a
couple more of our of our trig function
questions okay so if we kind of come
back up here we just found cosine of PI
sixths which is square root of 3 over 2
but let's answer it for a couple more
complicated ones right so for I'm
dealing only with angles that were
between 0 and 90 degrees or I should say
between zero and PI halves but let's try
a question that's a little bit different
from that and what if I instead said
cosine of negative 2 PI over 3 ok now
that's one that is hard to think of in
terms of triangles because what does it
mean to have a negative angle so this is
a good reminder that cosine and sine
even if you think they're about
triangles are really about circles and
remember if you walk all the way around
the circle and if it has a radius of one
walking all the way around the circle is
going to take you a distance of 2 pi and
so if you want to think about 2 pi
thirds what you might start by doing is
chopping the triangle into thirds and
then using that to help guide the
intuitions but again I kind of want to
do this as a live quiz so let's go ahead
and pull up the next question and have
you guys answer this for me
what do you think the cosine of two pi
divided by three now let's go ahead and
pull it up cosine of negative two pi
divided by three yeah so again if you're
keeping notes that can be very helpful
you reference your notes now look just
to make sure that you have enough time
to think this through I'm gonna go ahead
and give you a little bit more of that
pause and ponder music
it looks like one of you figured out how
to submit an answer that is not one of
the four multiple choices so other than
that we've got a very strong lead with
eleven hundred and fifty two of you as I
say this agreeing on one of the answers
and then second place by about a factor
of four is gonna sit on another one I'm
curious about actually what what all the
answer distribution here is I'm very
curious about oh now we have a sixth
okay so two of you have now gone outside
the realm of the typical multiple choice
universe and have entered your own
things two of you sit there and say I
don't want one of your choices I figured
out my own answer and you just didn't
put it in your form so I'm gonna figure
out a way to submit it differently if
only you could do that on the SAT what
is the answer a through e sir I think
the answer is J 1729 we got Rama
Newton's constant oh if I pause it now
though it's not going to stay there for
a brief glorious moment we had a
wonderful number they make composite
around the year though cuz it's 1999
20 31 okay well I've posited in the
future so the correct answer in this
context is negative one-half okay and it
looks like the second most common answer
was D which is negative root three over
two okay so that's very good because
often is kind of this back and forth
between whether you think it's a half or
whether you think it's root three over
two because it's sort of the difference
between things that feel like 30 degree
angles and things that feel like 60
degree angles so let's take a look back
at our drawing and see how we might
think about this so like I said negative
2 pi divided by 3 that's taking us a
negative distance over here and this is
why cosine will be a negative number
because the x-coordinate is pointing in
the negative direction and if you want
to think of this in terms of triangles I
might draw this triangle here and ask
what is this angle okay we know that
it's 90 degrees plus something or PI
halves plus something and negative 2 PI
over 3 if we wanted to think
in terms of degrees if that's something
we're more comfortable with that's
negative 360 divided by three you know
degrees which is negative 120 degrees so
if it takes 120 degrees to get around
here then that minus the 90 degree angle
between the X and y axis gives us 30
degrees okay so then the question is
what is the cosine of this value what is
the x-coordinate there with your
30-60-90 triangles it's just kind of a
nice thing to remember that the shorter
side is 1/2 and the longer side is root
3 over 2 and if you forget why it's
exactly the diagram that we just drew
before associated with equilateral
triangles right because if you imagine
taking an equilateral triangle and
chopping it in half then the shorter
side has length 1/2 and then the longer
side comes from the Pythagorean theorem
so congratulations to those of you who
correctly found that now I want to bring
back that identity that you guys found
at the very beginning ok associated with
cosine squared and cosine of 2 theta and
show how that extends our capability for
making some of these computations and
figuring out certain values so let's
remind ourselves what that actually was
okay I'm gonna go back here I'm gonna
pull up again the desmos graph and
remember how what we said is that cosine
squared which looks like this little
scaled-down version of cosine
oscillating more quickly is the same as
cosine of 2x that quicker oscillation
but we had to kind of shift it and
rescale it to make them equal so now
we're going to use that fact that you
can discover just by playing around with
graphs to make a computation that
otherwise would be pretty tricky to make
and I think that when you're able to
make concrete computations it's often a
reflection of the fact that you have a
deeper conceptual understanding of
what's going on so even if it's always
going to be your calculator computing
this you're not sitting here working out
cosine values by hand the fact that you
can is an illustrate that you understand
that cosine function a little bit better
so over on our paper let me write down
again what that identity was let's go
back to black good old friendly black
sine squared of X using the dum-dum
convention is 1 plus cosine of 2x this
is kind of oscillating more quickly all
divided by 2 okay so now I'm going to
ask you a trickier question which is
going to be what is the cosine of PI
twelfths okay and for those of you
keeping track PI twelfths is the same as
15 degrees so if we were doing this with
a unit circle what you might think is
okay a 30 degree angle so it's looking
like this that's 30 degrees I'm now
going to be taking half of that a half
of that and I want to know the cosine of
this value which is going to be the
x-coordinate of that value and right
away you can probably make a guess that
it's very close to one right because
it's a small angle and the small angle
means that our we haven't walked that
far around a circle so we haven't gotten
that far away from one especially given
the fact that as you start to walk
almost all of your velocity is in the up
and down direction alright so cosine of
PI 12 15 degrees you know what's about
to happen you know that this is a live
quiz dynamic so let's pull it up
all right what is the cosine of pi
divided by 12 okay lots of answers
rolling in very fun very exciting again
if you just happen to be tuning in now
you haven't been following along before
go to 3 B 1 B coast live your answers
will become part of what you're seeing
on screen it affects the overall
distribution this one unlike what we had
before much less overall consensus and
it definitely seems to be taking a bit
more time so I'm going to just stop
talking and give you some some pause and
ponder moments here because this one is
tricky this one takes time to think
through
now it looks like there's a total of
five of you who have extended beyond the
realm of usual multiple-choice by the
way as you guys are entering answers
here let me just say a huge thanks to
Ben eater and cam Christensen they're
the ones who actually worked on the item
pool website that is making all of this
possible either many of you might
recognize from his own youtube channel
named Ben eater about computer
engineering if you haven't checked it
out you absolutely should and then item
pool is a pretty cool thing that will be
unfolding over the next coming months
and year so you might want to keep your
eye on that it looks like some more
consensus is starting to form so I'm
gonna go ahead and grade this question
it looks like I'm getting a phone call
awesome so the correct answer is B which
is square root of it's a very
complicated thing right square root of 1
plus the square root of 3 over 2 divided
by 2 so congratulations to the two 2 to
9 of you who - 2 - 4 - 2 4 3 2243 of you
how are the answers still changing gonna
have to talk to caman eater about that
my hands are not on this who got that
correct now it looks like the second
most common answer was a which is of a
very similar form there's just a minus
sign in there so it's probably the case
that while doing the arithmetic
something got flipped we're going to
walk through it in a moment so you can
see and a special congratulations to the
two of you who figured out how to submit
an @ sign on this who the three of you
who submitted an @ sign that's not the
correct answer but well done well done
four of you very nice alright
so clearly this is a complicated answer
but where does it come from
well if we look at our identity here the
key is that it's relating two times an
angle to the angle itself
so if we just plug this in for 15
degrees or 4pi 12th what we would get is
that the cosine squared of PI twelfths
okay if we enter that as X is equal to
one plus the cosine of two times that
value which is PI sixths PI sixths all
divided by two now the cosine of PI
sixths we know right that's the same as
our 30-degree angle here again when you
have a 30-60-90 triangle the shorter
side of that which is going to be the
sine in this context the shorter side is
one half and then the longer side is
square root of three over two assuming
that the hypotenuse is one which in the
context of the unit circle we always do
assume so that means that we now have
one plus the square root of three over
two that's what the cosine of PI sixths
was all divided by two which means our
final answer when we just want to say
cosine of PI twelfths no squared about
it is going to be the square root of
this value okay very interesting so this
is showing us that cosine and sine can
get complicated right we've got a
handful of values like PI sixths and PI
thirds where we can figure them out we
can have even more I won't call them
trivial values but easier to compute
values like cosine of PI where you would
look at your unit circle and say oh PI
that means I've walked half way around
so my x-coordinate is negative one right
but outside of just a handful of values
like that they're very hard to compute
by hand and in the olden days the only
way that people could compute them by
hand before something like the existence
of calculus would be measuring it right
you like draw out with a protractor and
you try to carefully see what the
coordinates are or layering on usage of
identities like this over and over in
ways that you can get approximate values
like this and just to check ourselves we
can actually go and plug this into a
calculator if we want it to something
like desmos and just see one how big the
value is and kind of confirm for
ourselves that they turn out to be the
same so if we pop over here and I just
typed something like cosine of PI over
12 point nine six five okay so like I
said very close to one and that's kind
of what we would expect and the answer
we just got was the square root of 1
plus the square root of 3 I gotta make
sure I do the divided by two correctly /
- right that looks correct but then all
of that was divided by 2 all that stuff
on the inside was divided by 2 and
indeed they're the same value and so
even just something like PI twelfths
we end up getting a very convoluted
image now like I said this is a
reflection of the fact that our cosine
identity that we found at the very
beginning just by playing through with
graphs
it's definitely non-obvious and what
we'll find next time is that this is
actually a shadow of the fact that
trigonometric functions are related to
complex numbers and the idea of doubling
the angle here corresponding to
multiplying by something twice not at
all a coincidence I think it's very fun
I'm excited to show you guys all about
that now what I wanted to do just to
finish things off here though was to
show two things that are not commonly
shown about the unit circle okay so we
see where a sine and cosine are but
there might be a couple questions where
is tan okay where in our picture do we
see tangent of theta and then also where
is cosine of X or cosine of theta
squared or with the dumb convention
cosine squared of theta so pulling up
another one of my infinite supply of
unit circles here actually you know what
this one's not going to have enough
y-axis so I'm going to do something that
I really shouldn't do which is to try to
use a compass live on camera I'm sort of
terrible at using compasses because it
always slips out for me but we're just
going to do this I'm so nervous that
this is gonna somehow slip out oh yeah
I'm actually didn't turn out too badly
hopefully the pencil shows up okay on
screen the reason I'm doing this is the
tangent is going to demand that we think
outside of the box that we think outside
of the circle in order
- geometrically interpreted you could
just ask about the the opposite divided
by the adjacent which is where that
sohcahtoa TOA comes from but what I
really want is a single length in our
diagram that corresponds to the tangent
so we can kind of get that nice
geometric intuitive feel for it and the
idea is we take that radius which is 1
and if we think of the fact that tangent
of theta
sohcahtoa is supposed to be the opposite
over the adjacent
I want a triangle where that adjacent is
equal to 1 okay so a right triangle such
that this one is the adjacent side to
our angle theta well in order to do that
let's just draw a right-angled
perpendicular line off of our radial
line and some of you might know that if
you draw a perpendicular line to the
radius of a circle it actually lies
tangent to the circle so you see tangent
this is where the word comes from then
what we have is a triangle where the
adjacent side to theta is 1 and then the
opposite side is this length here so
that length of there is the tangent of
theta right and so right now you can
kind of intuitively understand that as
theta is very small when the opposite
over adjacent is very close to 0 because
that opposite is close to 0 and the
adjacent is close to 1 well indeed this
length also is getting very close to 0
and then you can also think through what
happens as that angle approaches 90
degrees this is something I actually
Illustrated once before in a previous
video a a lesser-known video entitled
tattoos on math that fun fact includes
someone who is behind the scenes as we
say all of this right now but the idea
is that when you draw that tangent line
tangent is this length that I just
pointed out to you and that context you
could also think about cotangent there's
this whole other triad of trigonometric
functions that aren't worth teaching but
are kind of historical quirks that's
actually what that whole video was about
but from here you can just play around
with moving the angle theta and seeing
what that does to this tangent value to
that
length okay and using that intuition
actually I want you to place a guess on
what the graph of tangent of theta is
going to look like so once again let's
go over to our live question dynamic
again congratulations to those of you
who got the last one right and as our
final question before the end of this
particular stream which is a rather tall
question so it might actually pop up
over over below the values we have
available here is the final question I
just want you to guess what the tangent
of theta looks like when we graph it
yeah and it should be pulled up now and
oh there we go
it is rather tall though okay okay so
let me go ahead and pull up a separate
image for you here so that you can see
all of the options let's pop over here
and take a look okay so again if you go
to 3 B 1 B Co /live where the link is in
the description you can submit your
answers to this basically which one of
these graphs shows you the tangent of
theta okay unfortunately we're gonna
have to kind of switch back and forth to
see the statistics it looks like there's
pretty strong consensus in one direction
but I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give
you a little bit more time to think
about it if you want to don't feel
rushed don't feel like you have to jump
right into it
I went a little ambient pause and ponder
music while we're at it I'm mildly
addicted to it
all right so while you're answering so
as we can see some people are clearly
messing with the website and having fun
or there's a bug in the website to
answer various other things other fun
thing going on it seems like we've got a
couple comments in the in the JSON
associated with the answers so to the
person who decided to skip over my very
draconian limits on the live chat
dynamic and instead entered in JSON
comment through the answer forum forum I
really enjoyed this class thank you I
appreciate that
and I appreciate your your hockey
instincts you're gonna go far in life my
friend you're gonna go very very far so
let's go ahead and grade this question
here um it looks like we have very
strong consensus hopefully around the
correct answer and the correct answer is
a again maybe a little bit hard to see
on our on our indication of the question
over here but a is the graph that looks
like this and what you'll notice is it
starts at zero and then as you approach
PI halves it blows up to infinity okay
now in terms of the animations and the
the geometric interpretation of tangent
that should actually make sense because
if we go back to what we were looking at
as the angle blows up the angle doesn't
blow up the angle does a very modest
thing of simply going to PI halves a
fine number but the tangent of that
angle is going to just get bigger and
bigger and ultimately it's it's not
defined it's the same as dividing by
zero once you get to PI halves and then
after that if you play the same game
it's going to be it's going to be
considered a negative value which
basically comes down to the fact that
the opposite and adjacent sides of our
triangle are going to be considered to
have separate signs so the very last
thing that I want to talk about like I
said is the question of where does
cosine squared of theta show up in our
image because this is the very thing
that we opened with is trying to
understand cosine squared and you might
think oh if we can see that in our image
somewhere maybe it really reveals why it
looks like a miniature version of the
cosine wave now one of the naive things
naive but one of the first things you
might try to do is pull up the original
cosine animation that we had or
something like it and say oh well I'm
gonna take that cosine length and
literally square it I'm just gonna draw
the square based on that and if I were
to do this where I'm gonna plot the
length of that horizontal line and I'm
also going to plot the area of that
square you know it's a little bit
complicated it certainly shows us what
we already saw before which is that the
square of that value looks like another
cosine wave but this is something where
just by staring at the image it actually
doesn't yield much insight I think
oftentimes in geometry or math when you
simply write down the definition of
things the answer pops out this is a
sign that again it's not trivial it's
very unclear why the way that that
square that literal square would
oscillate is going to be related to
cosine much less cosine of two theta so
it's going to come from somewhere else
inside our image okay and for that let
me go ahead and draw a much bigger
triangle for ourselves let's say we've
got one of these guys that was living
inside the unit circle this by the way I
think is the most exciting part of the
lecture so if there was just one thing
that you were going to stick around for
I would say that this is the thing that
you should because it gives a very
sneaky proof of the Pythagorean theorem
it might feel like a circular argument
at first but I assure you that it's not
and I also assure you that the word
circular was not meant as a pun there so
remember if that's our angle theta then
one of our side lengths is sine of theta
and the other one is cosine of theta let
me ask you if I draw well okay so you
know the example we had earlier was this
leaning tower thing where we kind of
imagined casting a shadow from a leaning
tower onto the ground this is sort of
gonna flip it on its head and say well
this angle theta between them who's to
say who's the tower and who's the ground
what if I wanted to have a light source
over here and I wanted to cast a shadow
from the ground onto the tower right a
nice perpendicular line in this
direction that way my angle
is going to do double duty for me right
it's describing angle between these two
lines but in one context this ground
line was the adjacent side it was the
short side but now if I ask you a
question like what is this side length
in the shadow that the ground lays down
on the tower if that's not more
confusing than I want it to be what are
we going to get well in terms of this
smaller right triangle that we've just
created by definition the cosine of that
angle is going to be the adjacent side
the thing we want to know maybe I'll
call it s for shadow again I'm going to
write down what it equals it's going to
be the adjacent side divided by the
hypotenuse but for this little triangle
the hypotenuse is cosine so it's divided
by the cosine of theta which means
cosine squared of theta dumb convention
is equal to the answer that we want let
me just write it down in a different
color to really emphasize cosine squared
of theta and let me emphasize this is
not using the Pythagorean theorem in any
way this is not having the cosine
squared arrived because we were assuming
that this sits on a circle where x
squared plus y squared equals 1 we're
just using the definition of cosine
twice to cast one shadow and then to
cast another now you can probably see
where this is going do the same thing
for the sine of theta so another place
where theta shows up in our diagram is
right here and a way that you can see
that is that this angle plus something
must equal 90 degrees right but this
other something plus R theta had to be
the remaining angles of the little right
triangle that we had what you might
think up here I can just give it a
different name if I called this other
angle alpha then we know that alpha plus
theta alpha plus theta plus 90 degrees
or PI halves if you want to get used to
the better conventions has to equal PI
that's got to equal 180 degrees this is
maybe confusing just think alpha plus
theta plus PI halves and the back of
your mind you can go to 90 degrees if
that's something you want for
for comfort but that also implies that
when we have a new right triangle
sitting here this little angle here has
got to be theta because it's alpha plus
90 plus something so that something's
got to be theta now the reason I have
stated that so much is because we're
gonna play our same shadow casting game
to figure out what this side length is
now with respect to that we have sine of
theta of this theta in particular is the
opposite the new shadow we don't know
I'll call it s prime is equal to s prime
divided by the hypotenuse well on this
smaller right triangle what was the long
side has become the hypotenuse so that
sine of theta sine of theta which means
sine squared of theta is our other
shadow this here is sine squared of
theta so that's kind of cool the side
length which was by definition 1 because
we've always been rescaling our
triangles such that the hypotenuse is 1
can be broken down into one part that's
cosine squared and another part that
sine squared and the way to break that
down is to just draw a single line the
perpendicular projection from our corner
point on to onto that hypotenuse so that
means is every time you see a unit
circle out in the wild which I'm sure
you do pretty regularly and you draw the
standard triangle to understand sine and
cosine so that height is going to be
sine the x-coordinate is going to be
cosine and our hypotenuse is always 1 so
that hypotenuse is 1 if this is Theta
and you ask yourself where is cosine
squared in this diagram where is sine
squared you can just draw a little
perpendicular line here and the part on
the bottom is cosine squared so Coast
squared of theta is this length this
length here and what we'll do in a
future lecture actually I want to talk
about geometry and geometry proofs and
in particular one that comes up all the
I've used it in many past videos it's
high time we just sit down and say how
would you prove it is the inscribed
angle theorem so after showing you how
complex numbers play into things next
time I want to turn back to this
particular diagram to give another very
intuitive understanding for the identity
that you found simply by playing around
with graphs at the very beginning here
which again is a very non-trivial
identity that the cosine squared of some
value is 1 plus the cosine of 2 times
that value divided by 2 the more
standard way you see it by the way if
you're to look this up in a textbook
instead of writing this as X this is
commonly written as something like alpha
halves for some angle and then 2x would
be alpha and the whole thing ends up
looking like cosine of alpha divided by
2 is equal to the square root of 1 plus
cosine of alpha divided by 2 I for one I
have such trouble memorizing the trig
identities and I always would just sort
of read arrive them on the fly and this
is one where I think the easiest way to
read arrive is to practice kind of
smashing around graphs in your head when
you have the 1 key insight which is that
squaring cosine gets you a smaller
cosine graph and the next time I'll show
you how complex numbers help you kind of
read arrive a bunch of other identities
on the fly but this one in particular I
just always have trouble remembering
it's called the half angle identity and
I just think it's delightful that before
you even know any trigonometry simply
hopping over to something like desmos
and being a little bit playful that I
mean that lands you on a highly
non-trivial fact and once again it's one
that indicates that cosine is related to
Exponential's that's not obvious and
hopefully next time we can start to get
a glimpse of why thanks for sticking
around this long thank you once again to
cam and Ben eater who have been making
the item pool magic behind the scenes to
get us our live statistics and I'll see
you go at the very end I had almost
everything down into the very end I will
see you all on Friday
[Music]